[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados crecen los temores
de una posible recesión económica en
eeuu y de sus posibles consecuencias en
otras partes del mundo pero qué es una
recesión económica qué tan grave podría
ser y qué implicaciones tendría para
américa latina una recesión se da cuando
la economía de un país se registra
durante dos trimestres seguidos o más un
crecimiento negativo del pib respecto al
mismo trimestre del año anterior en el
primer trimestre del año la economía
estadounidense se contrajo en un 16 por
ciento respecto al mismo trimestre del
año pasado y en el segundo lo hizo en el
0,9 por ciento para algunos esto
significa que entró en recesión pero la
casa blanca cree que hay otros factores
que demuestran que todavía no se ha
llegado a ese punto
no creo que eeuu esté actualmente en
recesión y la razón es que hay
demasiadas áreas de la economía que
están funcionando muy bien y por
supuesto yo señalaría el mercado laboral
en particular
analístas esta situación es consecuencia
de las políticas monetarias en la
pandemia cuando los países desarrollados
tuvieron un gasto público excesivo dando
ayudas para que los ciudadanos siguieran
comprando bienes y servicios mientras
que los bancos centrales mantenían en
mínimos sus tasas de interés hemos
vivido una época de 2020 2021 en la que
ese aumento masivo de la masa monetaria
por parte de la reserva federal y con
ello el aumento también del gasto
público para dar cheques a las familias
para hacer un plan de estímulo etcétera
pues ahora está generando ese efecto
resaca como le llamo yo el poder
adquisitivo aumento pero la oferta no
dio abasto lo que aumentó la inflación
drásticamente por lo que la reserva
federal comenzó paulatinamente a subir
sus tasas de interés en junio de eeuu
registró una inflación de 9,1 por ciento
interanual la más alta en los últimos 40
años subir tasas de interés es la
herramienta que tienen los bancos
centrales para frenar una inflación
galopante con esta política monetaria se
busca fe la economía como haciendo más
caros los créditos lo que hace que tanto
para ciudadanos como para empresas sea
más difícil endeudarse frenando así el
consumo pero no es una solución mágica
ya que una subida drástica de tipos de
interés puede estancar la economía y
generar una recesión una situación
ligada a un contexto internacional
complejo la guerra en ucrania ha
reducido las exportaciones de petróleo y
gas rusos lo que ha disparado los
precios de los combustibles a nivel
internacional además la pandemia sigue
causando estragos con los rebrotes en
china que han forzado en nuevos
confinamientos perturbando otra vez las
cadenas de suministro que tan profunda
puede ser esta recesión uno de los
grandes temores al oír hablar de
recesión es que ésta se convierta en una
como la vivida a partir de 2008 con la
crisis de las hipotecas expertos
consideran que la situación actual es
diferente y que en caso de recesión
ahora los bancos presentan estructuras
más sólidas en el año 2007 había
profundos desequilibrios financieros los
bancos estaban cuando en forma bastante
irresponsable
y eso llevó a que el sistema financiero
sufriera por bastante tiempo en este
momento y hay endeudamiento hay
problemas pero la gente la gente de a
pie se ha endeudado menos actualmente
también hay una situación de empleo más
robusta la tasa actual de desempleo es
de 36 por ciento y no se prevé que
aumente a más de 46 por ciento del
próximo año según bank of america esto
está lejos del escenario de la gran
recesión con cifras de desempleo de
hasta dos dígitos por otro lado cabe
también recordar que en 2021 las
economías casi en todo el mundo
presentaron crecimientos muy elevados
dentro de lo que se conoce como el
efecto rebote porque se comparan con los
picos negativos de 2020 cómo puede
afectar una recesión económica de eeuu
américa latina los expertos consideran
que los países más afectados serían
aquellos que más se exportan hacia ésta
unidos como méjico cualquier situación
económica de estancamiento y de
inflación pues afecta directamente a las
economías dependientes de eeuu en este
sentido pues yo veo un poquito más de
libertad de los países de américa del
sur que tienen un poco más
diversificado su comercio por otro lado
los vientos de recesión están generando
amplia demanda por lo que se considera
activos refugios como el dólar lo que ha
hecho que la moneda estadounidense se
fortalezca debilitando a su vez a otras
en países como colombia que vive un
histórico cambio de gobierno o chile que
enfrenta un posible cambio de
constitución la devaluación de las
divisas nacionales ha sido mucho más
pronunciada este debilitamiento de la
mayoría de divisas locales afecta
también el precio de los commodities o
materias primas locales que se exportan
desde la región impactando también el
poder adquisitivo y aunque la región
tiene otro socio importante china el
gigante asiático también puede verse
afectado por lo que pasa en eeuu
además de que viene de meses difíciles
por cierres que mencionamos
anteriormente que puede venir ahora en
eeuu se prevé una nueva subida de tasas
por parte de la fed lo que podría
controlar los precios pero también
acentuar el riesgo de recesión
así esta crisis podría derivar en lo que
se llama una estanflación es decir
cuando el crecimiento económico del país
se estanca a la vez que los precios
siguen al alza por la inflación aunque
diversos expertos concluyen en que de
haber recesión ésta podría no ser tan
fuerte como crisis anteriores es difícil
todavía determinar cuál sería su
verdadero impacto si le sirvió el vídeo
para entender las alertas de recesión en
eeuu los esperamos en otro episodio de
cinco minutos en france 24 y france 24
puntocom